dr jack bright was having the second
worst day of his life and things weren't
about to get any better he ran down the
main hall of sight 19 medallion jangling
against his chest all around him sirens
blared and warning lights flashed a
stark threatening red he cursed and
muttered under his breath just an hour
ago things had been under control
neat and orderly standard running
operations and now they were staring
down the barrel of both a broken
masquerade scenario and a potential xk
class end of the world scenario and on a
more personal level four of the meanest
nastiest and deadliest anomalies were on
his tail they breached containment
site security and now they were out for
revenge what was happening how had this
group of anomalies gotten out and why
were they all after dr bright and most
importantly of all how could everything
have gone to hell in a hand basket so
fast let's rewind the clock and see the
morning had begun in the break room dr
bright was enjoying a nice cup of hot
coffee and a danish watching the news it
was by all accounts an incredibly boring
day the reports were economic figures a
few dry statistics about unemployment
and then live coverage of a presidential
press conference on the white house lawn
dr wright was halfway through a thought
about how he'd hated his brief period of
time inhabiting the body of george w
bush and running the country when the
president started melting over his
podium on live tv as well as his guards
and the press corps and the camera
people it was a sight so shocking and
made dr bride drop his coffee cup and
almost drop his danish he slipped out
his phone and fired off a text to 05-1
the leader of the o5 council simply
saying we may have a problem to which he
received the quick and emphatic reply ya
think dr bright started frantically
changing the channel he wanted to know
if some anomalous troublemaker had just
melted the president and those around
him perhaps to destabilize the u.s
government that be a textbook chaos
insurgency move or if they were looking
at something considerably more dangerous
and considering every single channel dr
bright changed to started displaying a
signal interrupted message now is
probably not the time to be optimistic
it was here the big one the one they'd
all been waiting for
battle stations
engage
across site 19 the protocols were
enacted to put everything on total
lockdown nobody in nobody out it was
lucky for everyone inside that hadn't
already been exposed that this protocol
also involved the automatic shuttering
of every single window in the building
dr bright and a crack team of senior
researchers and administrators gathered
in the sites command center and opened
up a live video link to o5-1 they might
make some sense of all this chaos now
and figure out a good battle plan so
what's the situation boss dr bright
asked 05-1 let out a deep rattling sigh
well jack things are about as bad as
they'd ever been so i'll try my best to
take inventory a quarter of the council
is gone they got exposed and stopped
reporting in during the initial shift
that includes 05-9 on the orbiting base
given she probably got the most direct
exposure a senior administrator raised
their hand and asked
exposure to what sir oh 5-1 took a grave
pause before saying
sunlight that seems to be what we're up
against here the one common denominator
that seems to connect everyone
experiencing these anomalous effects is
direct sunlight exposure it causes
people to take on a kind of
gelatinous state and it isn't just
people either it's all living anomalies
too
something about this new sun thing it's
almost like it cancels out all previous
anomalous effects the only anomalies
that seem to be exempt are the ones who
aren't even made out of flesh dr bride
who had a tendency to make jokes as an
emotional defense mechanism when things
got tough chimed in with on a
semi-related note anyone here feel like
taking the lizard for a walk the few
nervous chuckles in the room were cut
off by 05-1 slamming his fist against
the table over the video link everyone
fell into a deathly silence damn it jack
this is no laughing matter the
foundation and the rest of the human
race is decimated right now we're
looking at billions dead already or at
least changed and even our people a good
portion of them are reading the tea
leaves and abandoning their posts to
spend what could be their last hours
with their families it is imperative we
take control of this situation right now
it may be our last chance so get your
asses in gear and make it happen and
with that the video link was cut off and
the ragtag leaders of site 19 got to
work taking what they knew about this
lethal new scenario dr bright had his
subordinates record and release one of
the most significant videos of the 21st
century or perhaps even all of time to
be broadcasted on every communication
channel the foundation could possibly
hijack tv radio social media youtube
twitch all global news outlets the scp
foundation was going public people all
over the world huddled in the dark
terrified of the horrors they'd seen
through windows or out of the safety of
shady corners noticed that all the
screens around them started playing the
same thing in perfect synchronicity it
was flashing red with an unfamiliar logo
while a commanding voice droned on with
the only instructions that might give
them hope for survival this is a public
service announcement from the scp
foundation we are commandeering all
broadcast channels and frequencies to
deliver a vital message avoid sunlight
at all costs cover your bodies
thoroughly and follow the instructions
on the screen to reach the nearest
operational scp foundation containment
site back at site 19 dr bright and
everyone they had left were preparing
for a sudden influx of refugees from the
outside any members of d-class personnel
who weren't psychopathic killers were
deputized as honorary foundation
personnel and brought in to convert
empty wings into sleeping and living
areas bride who is still trying to hold
on to some semblance of humor in this
dark time thought to himself well if i
knew we were going to be entertaining
guests i would have cleaned up the place
a little more you know maybe bought some
new throw pillows and a scented candle
or two and make no mistake it was indeed
an incredibly dark time it had only been
a few hours since the phenomenon started
and already it was hell out there
society had already effectively
collapsed during the chaos the streets
were filled with the shambling remains
of melted nightmare people the sun shone
far above like some all-powerful tyrant
gazing its single deadly eye down on all
of humanity for billions upon billions
of years it had given this solar system
life now all it had for them was death
and destruction for those trapped
outside there was only one hope of
survival getting to one of these scp
foundation containment sites at least
those people somehow knew what was going
on here little did these unfortunate
refugees of a horribly and irreparably
changed world know that all was not well
in the world of the scp foundation as
the hours marched on broken masquerade
scenario and possible xk aside it seemed
to dr bright that they actually had a
handle on the situation all things
considered and what's more the night was
about to fall allowing for free movement
outside this would be a boon for people
hoping to reach site 19 with minimal
risk of exposure but refugees wouldn't
be the only thing coming to site 19 that
day hours earlier and miles away
something terrible happened at
containment area 25 b an extensive and
heavily guarded containment site with
only one inmate during the initial panic
of the event that they were now
codenaming when daybreaks many of the
guards were exposed and several others
abandoned their posts in panic knowing
that the world as they had all grown to
know it had come to an end this left the
place grievously underguarded 200 meters
under the sea in the true heart of the
containment area an obsidian coffin was
surrounded by a confused and terrified
skeleton crew and the term skeleton crew
was about to take on a far more literal
meaning as the obsidian coffin they were
trying in vain to keep contained
started to rattle fast forward by 20
minutes and every single member of
foundation personnel at containment area
25b was dead and scp-076-2
the legendary immortal warrior abel was
standing in the ruins of the base while
it would be easy to write abel off as a
mindless killing machine because of the
sheer ferocity he brings to a battle the
reality couldn't be further from the
case he had the kind of tactical
intelligence that human supercomputers
wouldn't develop for another several
centuries if the world hadn't ended
already from the visual evidence he'd
gleaned upon escaping he already knew
that sunlight had turned deadly turning
everyone who was exposed into these
feeble blobs so if he hoped to continue
his killing frenzy elsewhere he'd need
to create his own shade during transit
that would be simple enough with a cruel
smirk abel picked up one of the
reinforced blast doors he'd so easily
burst through earlier the sheer weight
of it would have crushed a mortal man
but for abel this was little more than a
light workout he lifted the door above
his head like a parasol bathing himself
in the cool shade before taking off at
impossible speeds he'd remembered a lot
from his days under the foundation's
employ as part of the disastrous
pandora's box mobile task force and one
of those things was the location of site
19. there'd be plenty of warriors for
him to send to their makers there back
at site 19 where abel would very shortly
arrive dr bright and his team were
helping the first wave of outsiders into
the confines of the building at first it
had seemed like a good idea something
they could sustain but now dr bright was
starting to worry about all the
practical considerations how would they
keep potentially thousands or even tens
of thousands of people fed clothed and
watered for an extended period of time
sure they had the infinite pizza box but
pizza for three meals a day for weeks on
end was a fast track to everyone here
dying of scurvy these new worries were
interrupted by a siren that signaled
familiar ones there had been a
containment breach in several cells in
the humanoid containment wings some of
the low risk or even friendly humanoids
like scp-343
aka god had been led out to assist in
gathering survivors from the nighttime
chaos outside that meant anyone still
locked up really really really needed to
stay locked up in other words it was
very bad news dr bright cursed under his
breath and instructed his subordinates
to keep focusing on the refugee
situation he shouldered an assault rifle
and took off into the bowels of the site
hoping he could at least head off the
escapees until some guards or mobile
task forces from smaller sites could
reach site-19 and help him in getting
them fully recontained now this is just
typical he thought to himself when it
rains it pours can never catch a break
around here can we i should have
followed my dreams and become a
competitive ice dancer then i never
would have dr bride's self-pity was
interrupted by a brutal punch to the
side of his head which laid him out
against the wall he turned vision
swimming and raised his assault rifle
hoping to find a target in the blur
that's when an obsidian blade swung at
impossible speed and cleaved his gun in
half he could feel his breath hitch in
his throat as his vision re-centered
itself and he saw the imposing tattooed
figure of abel standing above him
wielding one of his trademark swords his
dark eyes were burning with deadly
intent hello jack he said long time no
see
i imagine i don't need to remind you who
i am
abel laughed and dr bright felt his
muscles tense in rage of course he knew
abel not only had the homicidal maniac
been a consistent thorn in the
foundation side since day one but he'd
also been the one to change dr bright's
life forever it had been able who had
killed him as a junior researcher when
he was first carrying the
scp-963 medallion it was abel who had
cursed him with this terrible
immortality dr bright despised him to
his core i'd like you to meet a few
friends i made since i got here jack
abel said gesturing into the darkness of
the hallway who said i was bad at
teamwork it was like something out of a
nightmare first
scp-106 stepped forward dripping with
that terrible black tar his face twisted
into a manic grin that foretold inhuman
tortures to come then came
scp-953 the devilish polymorphic
humanoid claws and fangs bared tails
swaying and then bafflingly scp-2430
the immortal hitler clone dr bright
tried to move but found the tip of
abel's sword right in front of his face
it's funny jack abel said you are an
anomaly who kills to live how many
people have won your little necklace and
yet you can swan around as you please
while we rot away in containment we
think it's time for a little payback
right nodded that makes sense i guess
but why is he here he pointed to the
immortal hitler clone who sneered as
usual he thinks you're jewish said the
polymorphic humanoid in korean clearly
that wasn't korean but here we are dr
bright rose uneasily to his feet
honestly surprised that abel was
allowing him to do so he was lucky in a
sense it perhaps took a being as strong
as able to hold these others at bay as
much as dr bright despised the man he
offered a much quicker and more painless
death than the old man or the
polymorphic humanoid it wouldn't be
anything he hadn't experienced before
after all life could be a sick joke
sometimes so what's the plan you're
gonna kill me again dr bright asked the
four nightmarish anomalies all began to
laugh
well in the end yes abel said but the
world's gone to hell you people aren't
in control here anymore so we can take
our time
we will slaughter you and everyone else
in here if i were you i'd run jack he
didn't need to be told twice jack ran
for his life too scared to even look
behind him as the sound of footsteps got
louder the only way things could
possibly get worse is if he somehow
admits to all this suddenly developed a
hernia and the way this day was going he
really wouldn't have been surprised dr
bright turned a corner and somehow the
polymorphic humanoid was already there
standing in front of him she gave a
girlish giggle and swiped at him leaving
four ragged claw marks on his chest dr
bright winced in pain and started
running in the other direction he
reached an adjoining hallway and booked
it for the armory hoping there he'd get
some serious firepower but scp-106
suddenly faced through the wall next to
him grabbing dr bright by his lab coat
and throwing him against the opposite
wall with a flick of his wrist bright
scrambled to discard the coat already
being eaten away by the old man's
caustic fluids the old man was just
watching him and chuckled faintly amused
by the whole affair these damn anomalies
were in control now dr bright got up and
kept running the one saving grace was
the fact that all of these anomalies
were too sadistic to outright kill him
just yet so he still had the faintest of
chances he ran into the break room
tipping over shelves bookcases and
furniture to obstruct the path behind
him ever so slightly that's when he
heard the door behind him open followed
by a wave of furious german expletives
as the immortal hitler clone entered the
room to give chase however moments later
hitler fell to the ground clutching his
foot and wailing in agony you see due to
the circumstances of his creation joseph
stalin sarkic wizards there's a whole
thing we really can't get into it now he
felt pain at three times the intensity
of a normal human being leave a god i'd
stopped my toe he yelled dr bride kept
running from the break room he entered
the hallway that would lead him back to
the main barracks perhaps there he could
get some reinforcements and maybe he
could his thoughts were once again cut
off by abel suddenly appearing and
grabbing him by the throat his grip was
impossibly strong dr bright was already
seeing stars think you could get away
that easily able hissed with horrifying
strength abel slammed dr bright up
against one of the shuttered windows he
struck it with such a force he broke
through the shutter and the glass behind
it sailing down to the ground outside
they were lucky it was night time or
this all would have been over already
abel soon followed him down cracking his
knuckles and assuming a fighting stance
up on your feet jack abel said
i won't kill a man lying down no honor
in that jack rose feeling pain in every
inch of his body up against a seven foot
tall jacked monster of a man with
thousands of years of fighting under his
belt he stood mathematically zero chance
but perhaps he could at least get some
licks in he ran at abel screaming with
years of pent-up rage and tried to
attack him with a flurry of blows but
not a single one landed abel was able to
dodge every punch and returned them with
a force comparable to being hit by a
runaway train he knocked dr bright to
the ground and started beating him
relentlessly all these lives i've given
you all this extra time and still you
haven't learned how to fight pathetic
able roared punctuating his words with
blows perhaps in a thousand years you
might last 60 seconds against me you are
a waste of your gift
dr bright could already feel the life
leaving his body when something new
entered the equation he could barely
make it out through his bloody swollen
eyes but something huge was coming
towards them it was like flesh from so
many of the melted people had coagulated
into some huge mountainous blob it was a
sight so remarkable and horrifying that
even abel was distracted and dr bright
took advantage of the one chance that it
gave him he took off his medallion and
threw it at the mass the life left his
old body as
scp-963 deleted the collection of
tortured minds that had made up the
terrible flesh monster and replaced them
with only one dr jack bright he felt new
immense monstrous strength well up
through him he was in the body of a true
abomination and all of its power was his
now how about a round two abel he
thought the ancient warrior produced a
pair of ebony swords as dr bright sent a
swarm of fleshy tendrils at him abel was
quick slicing off many of them but there
was only so much he could take soon dr
bright's new body was grabbing abel's
every appendage holding him in place as
he struggled with all his anomalous
might but now dr bright's rage had
meaning with his new power to back it up
he'd get a little revenge at long last
time to go back in the box abel it took
longer than it would for any mortal man
but eventually it happened all the same
bright pushed and pulled in every
direction applying every kind of
pressure leveraging every ounce of his
terrible new mass onto abel's body until
crunch dr bright relaxed his new body in
a final cathartic relief dropping abel's
corpse to the ground there was no
denying after everything that happened
that it felt really really
really good the world may have ended but
at least dr bright got one win today now
go check out dr bright for president
scp-4444
bush versus gore and
scp-963 what would you do if you were
immortal like dr jack bright for more
strange battles and adventures from the
amazing dr bright